das ist wirklich ein ganz neuer blick
auf den quantensprung ein deutsches
forschungsteam hat jetzt ein atomares
kranken mikroskop entwickelt das
ultraschnelle laserpulse mit der
auflösung eines rastertunnelmikroskops
kombiniert so können erstmals die
bewegung von elektronen in einzelnen
molekülen sichtbar gemacht werden solch
ein kant mikroskop eröffnet der
forschung ungeahnte möglichkeiten krieg
zum science im future hier gibt es drei
mal pro woche spannendes heinz wewers
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke new so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
ein mikroskop das beim quantensprung zu
sieht solch ein atomares kanten
mikroskop wurde nun in stuttgart
entwickelt es ist tatsächlich in der
lage die bewegung von elektronen in
molekülen sichtbar zu machen und zwar
zeitlich und räumlich hoch aufgelöst
eine echte premiere denn das atomare
land mikroskop ist weltweit einzigartig
fachleute weltweit hoffen auf
spektakuläre einblicke in molekulare
prozesse die bislang im verborgenen
geblieben sind wie wurde der
quantensprung im film möglich und welche
forschungsbereiche könnten davon
profitieren alle spannenden
informationen zu diesem thema bekommen
wir jetzt hier von mir die bewegen sich
elektronen in einem molekül bislang war
es der fachwelt lediglich nur möglich
dass elektronen verhalten entweder
zeitlich oder räumlich hoch aufgelöst
abzugeben dabei ist das verhalten von
elektronen super spannend und
entscheidend für die gesamte materie zum
gibt es bestimmt unter anderem die
chemische bindung also den zusammenhalt
der kleinsten teilchen in chemischen
stoffen außerdem beeinflusst dass
elektronen verhalten die eigenschaften
von stoffen und steckt hinter jeder
elektronischen anwendungen ein
entscheidendes stichwort in diesem
zusammenhang der quantensprung in der
fachsprache meint dass die
kleinstmögliche änderung eines energie
zustandes in atomen die forschung muss
die elektronik in molekülen abbilden um
biologische prozesse und technische
anwendungen im detail verstehen zu
können beispiele die pflanzliche
photosynthese oder aber die entwicklung
von neuartigen elektronischen
komponenten und solarzellen doch bislang
scheiterten die fachleute an dem ab
bildungs methoden denn diese lieferten
teilweise nur schwer reproduzierbare
oder sogar widersprüchliche ergebnisse
das problem die bisherigen methoden sind
nicht in der lage die schnellen
elektronen abzubilden forschungsteams
weltweit also waren gezwungen techniken
anzuwenden mit denen sich dass
elektronen verhalten lediglich
rekonstruieren ließ zudem war man bisher
gezwungen eine entscheidung zu treffen
entweder für sehr genau oder sehr
schnell raster tunnel und
rasterkraftmikroskop sind zwar in der
lage scharfe bilder von atomen und
molekülen zu liefern die
rastertunnelmikroskopie verfügt über ein
auflösungsvermögen von einem zehn
kilometer das entspricht einem
billionstel meter extrem scharfe bilder
von einzelnen atomen das ist das
ergebnis für die schnellen elektronen
bewegung ist dieses mikroskopie
verfahren allerdings zu langsam anders
dagegen optische methoden die auf
ultraschnellen laserpulsen basieren
diese ermöglichen es tatsächlich
bewegungen im
sekundenbereich dingfest zu machen um
das zu verdeutlichen
eine attosekunde entspricht einer
milliardstel milliardstel sekunde in
solch eine attosekunde ist ein
lichtstrahl gerade einmal in der lage
ein wassermolekül zu durchqueren
typische elektronen dynamiken und
laserpulse liegen im bereich einiger 100
attosekunden dennoch haben auch die
optischen methoden mit ultraschnellen
laserpulsen einen enormen nachteil als
ergebnisse kommen räumlich nur grob
verwaschenen bilder heraus diese sind
weit jenseits der atomaren auflösung die
mit rastertunnelmikroskop möglich sind
also total unscharf oder total
verwaschen entweder ist der raum nur
undeutlich erfasst oder die zeit beides
gegen bisher nicht gleichzeitig eine
große vision ist also die beiden
verfahren zu kombinieren um die
jeweiligen stärken auszuspielen und die
jeweiligen schwächen auszumerzen dazu
sagt der forscher vom max planck
institut für festkörperforschung
wir haben schon seit einigen jahren
daran gearbeitet diese beiden techniken
so zu verbinden dass jede ihre stärken
ausspielen kann ohne ihre schwächen
einzubringen dem forschungsteam ist es
jetzt tatsächlich gelungen ein neues
atomares kanten mikroskop zu entwickeln
das weltweit einzigartig ist dieses
kombiniert die
rastertunnelmikroskopie mit
ultraschnellen laserpulsen so bekommt
man quasi nicht nur einzelne atome zu
sehen sondern kann diesen sogar bei
ihrer arbeit zusehen das neue atomare
kanten mikroskop ist nämlich in der lage
die bewegung von elektronen in einzelnen
molekülen sichtbar zu machen und das
gleichzeitig zeitlich und räumlich hoch
aufgelöst also nicht nur schnell sondern
auch sehr präzise die aufnahmen
offenbaren also wie angeregten
elektronen zwischen orbitalen wechseln
und das innerhalb von femtosekunden
bruchteilen ein quantensprung im film
also gut für den laien vielleicht nicht
so einfach zu erkennen doch für menschen
die sich damit auskennt ist das ein
quantensprung in diesem fall im wahrsten
sinne des wortes doch wie kann das sein
und wie ist diese entwicklung gelungen
moderne lasertechnik wird dabei mit der
rastertunnelmikroskopie kombiniert die
mikroskop spitze wird atom genau
positioniert darauf werden dann die
attosekunden pulse gefeuert so entsteht
eine lokale anregung die eine elektronen
bewegung auslöst dadurch gibt es
detektiert bahre veränderung des tunnels
stroms zwischen dem mikroskop spitze und
des materials bei einem
rastertunnelmikroskop fährt eine
hauchfeine automat dünne spitze ganz
knapp über eine leitende oberfläche
entlang elektronen können dann zwischen
der oberfläche und dem mikroskop spitze
fließen der grund dafür ist der
sogenannte quantenphysikalische
tunneleffekt die elektronen können den
weg von der probe bis zur spitze
rechnerisch nicht überwinden doch der
tunneleffekt macht das quasi doch
möglich und ein kleiner stroms zu messen
ein molekül kann somit schrittweise atom
für atom ab gerastert werden bei der neu
entwickelten atomaren mikroskop ihr
technik wird der tunnelstrom durch
gezielte anregung von elektronen in
material mit der hilfe von laserpulsen
moduliert dazu sagt einer der beteiligt
wissenschaftler alberto martin krimis
das muss extrem schnell geschehen da
sonst etwa thermische effekte zum tragen
kommt und die messungen unmöglich machen
notwendig dafür sind ultra schnellen
laserpulse im aktuell sekundenbereich
doch dank der lasertechnik die in den
vergangenen jahren immer weiter
optimiert wurde konnten die passenden
pulse erzeugt werden das mikroskop dass
die stuttgarter nun entwickelt haben ist
tatsächlich einzigartig in ihrer
aktuellen studie berichten die fachleute
wie sie die elektroden bewegungen in
molekülen direkt beobachten konnten bei
der neuen technik werden in schneller
abfolge zwei minimal zeitversetzte pulse
mit exaktem zeitlichem abstand
hintereinander auf das molekül
geschossen dabei wird das ab gerastert
diese prozedur wird mehrfach wiederholt
und dabei der zeitliche abstand zwischen
impulsen variiert so entsteht eine
spannende bildserie dieses elektronen
verhalten in dem untersuchten moleküle
wiedergibt und das mit atomarer
genauigkeit die ultrakurze pulse regen
die elektronen im molekül dabei zu
sprüngen zwischen den verschiedenen
orbitalen an die schnellen laserpulse
liefern also die informationen über die
elektronen dynamik währenddessen raste
das rastertunnelmikroskop das molekül
sehr präzise ab die räumliche auflösung
liegt bei diesem neuen verfahren bei
weniger als einem nanometer die
zeitliche bei weniger als einer
femtosekunde der wechsel der orbitale
der quantensprung konnte also quasi
abgefilmt werden eine echte premiere
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam damit
konnten wir erstmals die dynamik der
elektronen im molekül direkt abbilden
wie sie von einem orbital zu einem
andern springt das neu entwickelte
atomare kranken mikroskop eröffnet der
forschung ganz neue möglichkeiten denn
mit seiner hilfe können nicht nur die
bewegung von elektronen in supraleitern
oder in biochemischen molekülen verfolgt
werden auch der ladungstransport bei
chemischen reaktionen wird so offenbar
elektronen könnten also auf ihrem weg
durch prozessoren und computerchips
verfolgt werden ladungsträger könnten so
erheblich beschleunigt werden dazu sagt
klaus kern der direktor am max planck
institut für festkörperforschung
mit ultrakurzen nicht blitzen lässt sich
die frequenz mit der elektronen
schwingen vom gigahertz bereich
möglicherweise auf eine milliarde erz
peter herz streit die prozessortechnik
könnte also um das millionenfache
beschleunigt werden auch bei der
biophysikalischen reaktion oder auch für
die entwicklung von solarzellen und
transistoren könnte ein solches quandt
mikroskop entscheidende neue
erkenntnisse liefern sensation der
quantenphysik sind quantensprünge doch
vorhersagbar anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren bis dann bleibt da